foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
here back again with another review
today we are taking a look at the
Samsung Galaxy Tab S9 Ultra and how it
compares the iPad Pro 2022 for digital
app let's get started with some of its
features now the Samsung Galaxy Tab 9
Ultra features as you can already tell a
message screen at 14.6 inches but
surprisingly only 0.22 inches thin
making this a wide but slim model
weighing only 732 grams so you can
easily slide this into any backpack tote
bag or you name it it will probably work
it also comes with an S Pen stylus that
has a haptic audio feature for more
realistic writing experience not to
mention it is powered by the latest
Qualcomm Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 processor
and has up to 12 gigabytes of RAM 256
gigabytes of storage the Galaxy Tab S9
Ultra is super lightweight and for
anyone who is looking for that hyper
immersive screen while keeping everyday
load slide this might be perfect for you
as a 2d artist I was really excited to
try out the Samsung Galaxy Tab S9 Ultra
however I was a little disappointed with
the overall experience the screen is
definitely large and immersive and
provides a lot of real estate to move
around but I would say that the
experience is very different as someone
who is familiar with both digital and
traditional art mediums it just felt
like it took a lot more time adjusting
to such a scale that it makes it awkward
to use for drawing as my arm tends to
get in the way and for some I think this
might also be an issue especially if
you're cross hatching or shading
moreover it's rare that most artists
choose canvas ratios that are similar to
the tab S9 Ultra right now I'm working
on my traditional art portfolio and my
favorite size of Sketchbook is E5 it
covers about 40 percent of the tab S9
Ultra display area so it's in the
ballpark of an iPad Mini now when it
comes to the display experience itself
Samsung has always been at the top with
their displays the AMOLED display has
really good color reproduction colors
are really vibrant and bright comparing
the tab S9 Ultra with the iPad Pro 2022
I would say that these two screens are
pretty similar as mentioned before this
tablet comes with the S Pen stylus and
it has had some noticeable updates since
its predecessor one thing I really enjoy
is the haptic audio feature if you would
like more pseudo tactile feel then the S
Pen will actually make the sound as if
you're drawing on real paper
[Music]
foreign
I think that's something really cool
without having to use textured screen
protectors like the paper like one small
caviar that you would notice though is
that this haptic audio feature only
works on the Samsung Notes app and
unfortunately does not work on any other
third-party drawing apps like clip
Studio paint or high pane so that's
something to consider much like Apple
Samsung has adopted the magnetic
charging feature at the back of the
tablet which doubles as a holder but it
just sits in a very weird place for the
most part it will hold the S Pen in
place but it is concerning the fact that
you can't see the pen and could result
in losing the stylus it would have been
great if there was a built-in S Pen slot
integrator in the tablet much like the
Samsung Note back in the day I'm sure
you can all agree talking about the
S-Pen performance here I find it too
small for my liking and found it
difficult to control when drawing small
details compared to the apple pencil the
S Pen still feels too small for my
already small hands
although already much larger than
previous Galaxy Note pens it still has
dainty proportions which are also
dwarfed by the mammoth screen of the
tablet so all these small considerations
add up and skills the sense of space and
disrupts the creative flow something
that I think is pretty cool is that
Samsung has made some exciting
collaborations with Lemmy and Statler to
create their own versions of the S Pen
which could potentially make drawing
experience more comfortable and natural
I haven't tried them out myself yet but
I'm optimistic so with these
considerations with the tab S9 Ultra
stand against its other counterparts
like the iPad Pro
before we move on geek culture is
supported by Brands who help us improve
our content so stick around for this
sponsored message here geek culture
we've tested plenty of chairs but Secret
Life gaming chairs remain one of our
favorites whether it's for work or play
they feel great to lean back against
with the ergonomic features offering
support for the whole body from the head
and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of four men function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
in terms of overall performance the
Samsung Galaxy Tab S9 Ultra is
definitely up to the task of running
demanding our apps however I didn't
notice a significant difference in
performance compared to my iPad Pro
2022. overall I think the Samsung Galaxy
Tab S9 Ultra is a great tablet for
productivity and entertainment but it's
not the best choice for digital artist
if you're looking for a large immersive
tablet with great display fully
utilizing the huge screen for
productivity and note taking then the
Samsung Galaxy Tab S9 Ultra is a very
good option however if you're a serious
digital artist I would recommend
sticking with the iPad Pro 2022 no doubt
I can see Samsung trying to create their
own Edge against the iPads and apple
pencils but Apple just takes the lead
here just the right screen size higher
processing power and the ergonomics of
the apple pencil and simplicity of the
Apple ecosystem makes perfect sense for
me as an artist it just goes to show
that bigger doesn't always mean better
but I'm sure Samsung will improve their
tablets for creators in the near future
and that wraps up today's video I hope
you found this helpful please let like
subscribe and share it with your friends
and don't forget to check out more of
our reviews right here
[Music]
foreign